[موسيقى]
الحصان اليوم
وفي العاصمه القطريه الدوحه اجواء
المونديال تزداد حماسه في منافسات اليوم
الثالث وتشاهدون احدى مناطق المشجعين في
اخر مواجهات اليوم بين كندا وبلجيكا هذه
صور من حديقه البدع
وهذه من كورنيش الدوحه
واخيرا من كثره
في مواضيع الحصاد
للمره الاولى منذ سنوات تفجيران متزاملان
في محطتين للحفلات في القدس الشرطه
الاسرائيليه تعلن مقتل اسرائيلات وترفع
مستوى التاهب رئيس الاركان يقطع زيارته
للولايات المتحده والمرشح لوزاره الامن
الداخلي في الحكومه الجديده ثمار كثير
يدعو لاجتياح الضفه الغربيه
روسيا تكثف استهدافها البنيه التحتيه في
اوكرانيا انقطاع امدادات الكهرباء والماء
على كيف ومدن اخرى الجيش الاوكراني يقول
ان روسيا استادفت البلاد ب 70 صاروخ كروز
مجلس الامن يعقد اليوم جلسه لبحث التطورات
والكريم لمن يقولوا ان موسكو وثقه من نجاح
العمليه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
مع استمرار غارتها على ما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه
انقره تؤكد تصميمها على التحرك لتامين
حدودها الجنوبيه وتتهم قوى دوليه بعدم
الوفاء بعودها بشان الضمانات الامنيه وزير
الدفاع التركيه يقولوا انه تم استهدافه
اكثر من 470 موقعا وعلى وقع الترقب اتصال
بين رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه ونظيره
التركي وموسكو تدعو انقره لعدم شنه هجوم
بري في سوريا
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا التطورات في القدس بعد
مقتل اسرائيلي واصابه عشرات في تفجيرين
داخل محطتين متقاربتين للحافله بالقدس
الغربيه
كيف سنعكس هذا التطور على مشهد التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في الاراضي الفلسطينيه ثلاثه
وعشرون في المئه توقعوا اجتياحا اسرائيليا
للضفه الغربيه بينما توقع 27% شلنا
اسرائيل عمليه عسكريه محدوده في المقابل
قال 50% ان مستوى التصعيد سيبقى على حاله
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا في منصاتنا الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
ار الظاهري على الشاشه ولقائنا على المنصه
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وبعض الحصاد مباشره و تحديدا في الساعه
الثانيه عشر وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه
يوميات المونديال التي ترصد بالخبر
والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم قطر 2022
افادى مراسل الجزيره في القدس ان
اسرائيليه قتل في ما اصيب العشرات في
تفجرين داخل محطتين متقاربتين للحافلات
بالقدس الغربيه وقالت الشرطه الاسرائيليه
الى المتفجرات وضعت داخل حقيبه في كل من
المحطتين وفجرت عن بعد وفي رد فعل
اسرائيلي
في الحكومه الجديده لاجتياح الضفه الغربيه
اذا وقد فرضت المحكمه الابتدائيه في القدس
تعتيما اعلاميا لمده شهر على مجريات
التحقيق في العمليه
تفجير في القدس بل تفجيرا اذ لم تلتقط
الشرطه لاسرائيليه انفاسها حتى وقع تفجير
بعبوه ناسفه اخرى في منطقه قريبه
عمليتان اسفرتا عن مصرع اسرائيلي واصابه
اخرين بجروح متفاوته وفي اعقاب التفجيرين
رفعت الشرطه الاسرائيليه حاله التاهب في
القدس ومحيطها ضمن عمليات بحث ومطارده لمن
نفذ ما وصفت بالعمليه المزدوجه
القادم وهذا يعني ان تتحرك جميع القوات
على اعلى مستوى وفي كل الدوائر البعيده
وليس في القدس فقط
[موسيقى]
في الموقعين تطابقت اليه تنفيذ التفجير عن
بعد من خلال هاتف النقال وكذلك نوعيه
العبوه المستخدمه الامر الذي اربك الاجهزه
الامنيه بشان وجود منفذ او اكثر وما ادى
الى مزيد من الارباد هو حاله الصدمه التي
خلفتها العمليه جراء ما وصف بالاخفاق
الامني والاستخبارات
اخفاق طالب على اثره عدد من الساسه في
اسرائيل بالانتقام الجماعي من
الفلسطينيات الجسديه ووقف الاحتفالات في
السجون حيث يسخر من المخربون يجبوا اغلاق
السجون الامنيه حيث لا تكون هناك زيارات
ووقف دفن الاموال لكل من يقتل يهودا من
قبل هذه السلطه الفلسطينيه الداعمه
للارهاب وكل قريه يخرج منها مخرب يجب مسح
منازلها بالكامل كي نعيد الرد
منعطف خطير هكذا وصفت عمليات التفجير على
المستويين السياسي والامني في اسرائيل
التي تخشى ان يتفجر الموقف على نحو يصعب
عليها التحكم به فبدايه التصعيد في القدس
تحديدا لا تشبه نهايته لا تخفي الاجهزه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه خشيتها من ان تجر هذه
العمليه مزيدا من عمليات التفجير المشابهه
التي قد تعيد اسرائيل الى مرحله سابقه
تعود لسنوات عده مرحله
لطالما رجحه المؤسسه الامنيه
انها انتهت
نجوان سمري الجزيره القدس الغربيه
في الجهه الغربيه من مدينه القدس تفجيران
بفارق 30 دقيقه بينهما غير بعيد عن مبنى
الكنيست الاسرائيلي ومقري الحكومه
والمحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه
الانفجار الاول في الساعه السابعه وخمس
دقائق صباحا عند مدخل المدينه القدس على
طريق القادم من تل ابيب على بعد كيلو
مترات باتجاه الشمال الغربي عند مدخل حي
راموت الاستيطانيه وقع الانفجار الثاني
الساعه
7:35 دقيقه تقول الشرطه الاسرائيليه ان
العمليتين نفذتها بعبوتين فجرت عن بعد من
خلال هاتف النقال
ولم تعلم اي جهه حتى الان مسؤليتها عن
العمليه بينما صدرت مواقف عده من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه حيث قال الناطق باسم حركه حماس
عبد اللطيف القنوع تعقيبا على عمليه القدس
من العمليه تاتي في اطار الرد المستمر على
جرائم الاحتلال مؤكده ان محاولات الاحتلال
التحريض على حماس وعلاقاتها مع دول
المنطقه هي مساء للتغطيه على عجزه في
مواجهه ثوره الشعب الفلسطيني بجانبه قال
القيادي في حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه خضر
حبيب من المقاومه مستمره وان الشعب
الفلسطيني مصمم على انتزاع حقوقه مهما
بلغت التضحيات وقالت الجبهه الشعبيه
لتحرير فلسطين من العمليه رساله واضحه بان
الشعب الفلسطيني لن يسمح باستمرار ارهابي
جيش الاحتلال ومستوطنيه
وفي واشنطد البيت الابيض بالتفجيرين وقال
ان الولايات المتحده عرضت مساعده اسرائيل
في التحقيق وعبرت المتحدثه باسم البيت
الابيض كارين جون بيار في بيان عن اداره
البيت الابيض لما سمتها الاعمال الارهابيه
التي وقعت في القدس جته قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ان الاداره الامريكيه على اتصال
وثيق مع شركاء الاسرائيليين مؤكدا التزام
بلاده بامن اسرائيل جانبه اعلن الاتحاد
الاوروبي اذنته لما سماها الهجمات
الارهابيه في القدس وجاء في بين له انه
يشعر بقلق من تصعيد العنف في اسرائيل
والاراضي الفلسطينيه
نظام الينا من ام الفحم الدكتور مهند
مصطفى مدير مركز مدى الكرمل للدراسات
والخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي دكتور مصطفى
ااه ما هي دلالات التصريحات الاسرائيليه
حتى الان اعود واذكر بان ابن كثير قال
بانه يجب اقتحام الضفه الغربيه او اجتياح
الضفه الغربيه اضافه الى تصريحات
اسرائيليه تقول بان هذه العمليه مركبه
ومعقده الى ماذا يؤشر كل هذا
يعني هذا الشؤون هذا العمليه شكلت صدمه
للاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه لان هي تعتبر
منذ سنوات طويله نقله نوعيه في العمليات
الفلسطينيه المسلحه يعني حتى هذه اللحظه
كانت تعامل مع تنظيمات بسيطه او مع عمليات
فرديه لفلسطينيين للشباب ولكن هذه العمليه
هي تطور نوعي من حيث التنظيم من حيث العمل
اللوجستي وايضا من حيث العمل التقني وقلق
اسرائيل نابع عن هذه العمليه تحتاج الى
ترتيب مسبق طويل جدا ومع ذلك لم تستطع
الاجهزه الاستخطاطيه الاسرائيليه رصد هذه
العمليات او هذه الخليه التي نظمت له هذه
العمليه ولذلك هذا العمل يشكك بنسبه
الاسرائيلي صدمه على المستوى الامني وصدمه
ايضا على المستوى السياسي الان الحكومه
القادمه طبعا هي جاءت همم بخطاب عنفي
اتجاه الفلسطيني اكثر من ما هي حكومه بنت
لبيب ولذلك من متوقع ان تصعد الحكومه
القادمه عند تشكيلها من عملياتها العسكريه
في داخل الضفه الغربيه ويشمل ذلك ايضا
تكثيف الاستيطان بمعنى ان الحكومه اليمنيه
تعتقد انه لا يكفي فقط تصعيد العمليات
العسكريه بمختلف الادوات العسكريه
والقمريه والعنفيه تجاه الفلسطينيين ولكن
ايضا يجب ان يشمل ذلك تكثيف الاستيطان في
الضفه الغربيه من اجل تدفيع الفلسطينيين
كمان جراء هذه العمليات ولذلك تتوقع في
الحكومه القادمه لانه اصلا هذه الحكومه
جاءت من اجل ذلك يعني هي جوهر وجودها
وجوها الدعم الذي اعطي لمركبات هذه
الحكومه هو لكي تستعمل المزيد من القناع
لانه كان شعارها والامن الشخصي انت وصفها
بانها تطور نوعي وهذا ما تقوله بالمناسبه
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه كيف تفهم هذا
التطور تفجيرا عن بعد في وقت يعني اسرائيل
تحكم قبضتها الامنيه وتقوم باعتقالات
يوميه اختيالات ايضا في في الشوارع كيف
تفهم هذا
انا الشعب الفلسطيني بالذات الضفه الغربيه
الانمي مرحله مرحله جديده وهي تصعيد
المقاومه والعمليات المسلحه بالاسرائيل
يعني يجبها فقط ان نذكر انه في العام
الاخير هنالك في تصعيد عسكري اسرائيلي
تتضفه الغربيه غير مسبوق من
ضوء 2000 ويرافق هذا التصعيد ايضا عنف
المستوطنين عنف المستوطنين زاد تجاه
الفلسطينيين دون اي محاسبه وبالعكس تحت
حمايه الجيش وبصمه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
واين ذلك
مؤخرا في في في عمليه المستوطنين في داخل
الخليل ولذلك الفلسطيني بغيابه فوكس سياسي
وبضعف السكر الفلسطينيه وبتصعيد عسكري بدا
ايضا هو اللي يطول عمليات المسلحه يعني
خلال يعني خلال سنه من خلال المواجهه
المستمره بين اسرائيل وبين الفلسطينيين
ايضا الفلسطينيين اول من امكانياتهم
العسكريه والتنظيميه بحيث انهم اصبحوا
يقومون بمثل هذه العمليه وهي تحتاج الى
تنظيم معقد جدا ومع ذلك لم تستطع
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه رصد اي تنظيم او
اي ترتيب لهذه العمليه وهذا يؤشر ان الضفه
الغربيه لم تعد تحتمل عنف المستوطنين
الاستيطان الاشتياحات العسكريه الاشتياحات
اللي هي الاعتقالات الدائمه وقتل
الفلسطينيين لم يعد الناس اشكال التصعيد
كيف ستكون هل ستختلف عن التصعيد القائم
حاليا باقتضاب لو سمحت
اه طبعا يعني سيكون اول اكثر اجتياحات لا
لمده ضغط الغبيه بشكل مكثف اكثر هدم بيوت
اكثر اعتقالات اداريه اكثر
وممكن ايضا اغلاق بلدات فلسطينيه كامله
ولكن ابقى سعيد العقيد سيكون ليس فقط عن
المستوى العسكريه وانما ايضا على المستوى
الاستيطاني في الضفه الغربيه واعطاء حمايه
للمستوطنين والشرعنه الاستيطانيه موجوده
في الدقه الغربيه وهي بالمئات واضح هذا
التصعيد على المستوى العسكري وعلى المستوى
السياسي سيكون ضد الحكومه القادمه شكرا لك
الدكتور مهند مصطفى مدير مركز مدى الكرمل
لدراسات والخبير في شان الاسرائيلي
في شان الاسرائيلين اخر نقل موقع اكس يو
الامريكيه عن مسؤول رفيعا في الخليجيه
الامريكيه ان اداره الرئيس جو بايدن ابلغت
الكونجرس تعيين هادي عمر ممثلا خاصه لشؤون
الفلسطينيين ونقل اكسيوس عن مصدر فلسطيني
محمود عباس ابدا تحفظات بشان المنصب
الجديد في اول الامر لكنه اوضح في
الاسابيع الاخيره ان سلطه الفلسطينيه تتفق
مع القرار وستعمل مع عمرو وقد ابلغت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المنتهيه ولايتها بهذه الخطوه كما ابلغت
مسبقا رئيسا الوزراء المكلف بنيامين
نتانيا
ستكون لنا قراءه اكبر في هذا الخبر وكيف
تطورت العلاقه الامريكيه مع السلطه
الفلسطينيه ومنظمه التحرير هذه القراءه
ستكون ضمن فقره المتابعه بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
قال الجيش الاوكراني الذي اسقطت اليوم 51
صاروخا روسيا من اصل 70 استهدفت البنا
التحتيه الحيويه لاوكرانيا مصادر في حكومه
المجاوره اكدت انقطاع الكهرباء
من نجاح العمليه الخاصه في اشاره الى
الحرب في اوكرانيا
الكراهيه المقدسه وصف اطلقه برلماني روسي
الثلاثاء مشيرا لضربات بلاده ضد اوكرانيا
اعتبر عضو الدمى
تلك الضربات فاريه وفق تقرير مجله يزويك
وتوعد الاوكرانيين بالتجمد والتعفن دون
غاز او اضواء او اي شيء هل ترجم قصف
الاربعاء سريعا الوعيد الروسي قال الجيش
الاوكراني ان دفاعته الجويه اسقطت
الاربعاء واحد و 50 صاروخا روسيا من اصل
70 استهدفت البنا التحتيه الحيويه
ليوكرانيا
الاستهداف الصاروخي الروسي لمنشئه بنيه
تحتيه الى انقطاع المياه والكهرباء في
العاصمه سقط في القصف قتلى وجرحى لكن يبقى
ان التزام ناس استهداف البنا التحتيه
الاوكرانيه مع دخول الشتاء ينذر بمصير لا
يقل خطوره على الاحياء اصداء التصعيد تجا
حدوده اوكرانيا حيث اعلن نائب رئيس
الوزراء في مولدوفا ان انقطاع الكهرباء
بضع ساعات عن نصف مدن البلاد نتج عن القصف
الروسي على محطات طاقه اوكرانيه ليست
الهجمات الاولى فلم يفرغ بعد خبراء وكاله
الطاقه الذريه من تفحص ما لحق بمحطه زبرج
النوويه مسجلين اضرار كبيره قالوا انها لم
تمس الانظمه الاساسيه للمحطه التي ما زالت
مفاعلاتها وفق قولهم مستقره حاليا لكن من
يامن وعواقب التجدد استهداف منشات حساسه
كهذه مخاوف حملت الرئيس الاوكراني
فلودونيسكي على مطالبه الحلفاء الاوروبيين
باعلان روسيا دوله ارهابيه وكانت تجاوب
الاوروبيه على مستوى البرلماني معتبرا
الدوله الروسيه راعيه للارهاب ومستندا الى
ان الهجمات الروسيه في اوكرانيا تبلغ
مرتبه الاعمال الارهابيه ضد المدنيين
نهج الميداني الروسي الحالي في اوكرانيا
هجوما حادا من خصوم موسكو الذين يرون ما
تقدم عليه اله الحرب الروسيه فضائعه وليست
فوات او استثناءات للقاعده كما صرح وزير
الدفاع الامريكي قبل ايام تحث الحكومه
الاخرانيه مواطنيها على ترشيد استخدام
الطاقه وتواجه منظومه الصحه في اوكرانيا
احلى كايامها في الحرب على واقع اكثر من
700 هجمه وفق تحذير منظمه الصحه العالميه
اكد فرح الحق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده ان مجلس الامن سيعقد
اليوم جلسه مفتوحه بشان اوكرانيا وقال حق
في مؤتمر صحفي بمقر الامم المتحده ان
اوكرانيا تعرضت لموجه جديده من الهجمات
على البنيه التحتيه للطاقه ما ادى الى
تفاقم ازمه الطاقه بشكل خطير مشيرا الى ان
الهجمات تؤثر على وصول الناس الى المياه
والتدفئه في وقت تكون فيه درجات الحراره
اقل من الصفر في اجزاء كثيره من البلاد
كما حذر حق من ان مستوى المعاناه
الانسانيه في اوكرانيا يرتفع بشكل يومي مع
استمرار الحرب
علينا من موسكو اندري برولوف الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي
اذن سيد فلوف
الى اين تريد موسكو الذهاب في استهداف
البنيه التحديده البنيه التحتيه لمناطق
مدنيه في اوكرانيا
في الواقعه الاجابه على هذا السؤال عند
الحكومه الروسيه ولقد تكلموا عن هذا اكثر
من مره ان العمليه العسكريه الخاصه التي
تقوم بها روسيا يجب ان تنتهي ويجب ان
تنتهي على اساس الشروط التي اعلنت من
روسيا سابقا
ايي وهي تحديد
وجهه اوكرانيا السياسيه ونزع السلاح
وتحرير لوغانسك ودانيس لذلك روسيا تحاول
ان تبتعد عن الضحايا واا الضحايا سواء كان
في اراضي المعارك ونحاول ان نستخدم سياسه
اجبار كيف على ان تجلس خلف طاوله
المفاوضات وان تقوم
بعمليات
سوف تكون اقدر على الاقتصاد الاوكراني لم
تتحقق حتى الساعه على الاقل سيد فراغ يعني
مدنيون يسقطون اوكرانيا تزداد تشبثا بما
تقول بانه تطهير الاراضي الاوكرانيه من
الروس اي بمواجهه الروسيه في الجبهات
الشرقيه وايضا الجنوبيه وعلى الصعيد
المستوى على الصعيد الدولي البرلمان
الاوروبي اعتبر روسيا دوله راعيه الارهاب
اذا
الاهداف لا تتحقق بالنسبه لروسيا
سلطه على روسيا وهي لا تسيطر على السياسه
الروسيه بامكانهم ان يتخذوا اي قرارات اما
بالنسبه
لعمليه الخاصه ان هذه الضربات التي نقوم
بها الان
نرى ان الطقس ليس دافئ في اوكرانيا لذلك
تكرار هذه
القصفات وكل ما تطول الشتاء سوف يكون هذا
نوع من الضغط على الحكومه وعلى الشعب وعلى
المعنويه العسكريه للجنود وهذه الضربات
سوف يكون اثارها اكثر شده على الجنود
وروسيا تريد ان تبتعد عن سقوط الضحايا
ولكن علينا ان نشبر اوكرانيا ان تعود الى
طاوله المفاوضات اذا ما دمرنا البنيه
التحتيه من جانب اخر ان الدعم
الغرب الى اوكرانيا سوف يكون اكل فتى في
حال الدعم
اوكرانيا بالوقود وبقطع الغيار لي اعاده
بناء محطات الكهربائيه اوكرانيا الاساسيه
والرئيس زينسكي يرى بان يعني سلوك روسيا
في هذه المرحله لا سيما استهداف البنى
التحديه بعيدا عن سخونه الجبهات هذا يشير
الى ضعف روسيا في الجبهات الشرقيه
والجنوبيه خاصه
ما ردكم
الجيش
من الصعب ان نتحدث عن ضعف اي من الاطراف
لان هناك عمليات مستمره ساخنه واذا نظرنا
الى الفيديوهات التي نحصل عليها من
المعارك نحن نفهم ان الاوضاع الجويه
تجعل الاراضي غير صالحه لعبورها بالمعدات
سواء كان للروس او للاوكران امام تقوم به
روسيا فهذه قضايا روتينيه قامت بها حتى
امريكا وان كانوا يدمروا البنيه التحتيه
ومحطات الكهرباء حتى يجبر الحكومات لان
يعود لطاوله المفاوضات وحدث هذا في صربيا
لم ااه تصل اوكرانيا الى اي شيء ونحن نقوم
بامور
اعتياديه للوصول الى النتائج السياسيه
شكرا لك سيد اندريس الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي في موسكو
اذا فقدت محطه زبروج النوويه امكانيه
الوصول الى الكهرباء الخارجيه مره اخرى
وتعتمد على مولدات الديزل لتشغيل التبريد
ووظائف السلامه والامن النووي الاساسيه
وذلك وفقا للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
وقال المدير العام للوكاله رافاييل
ماريانو جروسي من الحادثه الاخير يصلي
الضوء على وضع الامن النووي المحفوفه
بالمخاطر في اكبر محطه للطاقه النوويه في
اوروبا بعد ايام قليله من قصفها بشكل
متكرر واشاره الوكاله الى ان المحطه فصلت
عن الشبكه الوطنيه عده مرات خلال الصراع
العسكريه الحالي في اوكرانيا وكان اخرها
في اوائل الشهر الحالي عندما استغرق الامر
يومين استعاده امدادات الطاقه الخارجيه
يضم الينا عبر الهاتف من كييف السيد سيري
هيك وزان المستشار في وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ورئيس المركز الاوكراني للامن
والتعامل السيد سرهي كان من المستند ان
تكون معنا بالصوت والصوره ولكن يبدو ان
ضرب ال ال البنيه التحتيه في اوكرانيا اثر
على ذلك على كل حال
مرد الحازم الذي يطالب به الرئيس جالينسكي
المجتمع الدولي تجاه روسيا
التاريخ التاريخ
ساعود اليك سعيد السؤال عليك الرئيس
جليلنسكي طلب المجتمع الدولي برد حازم ما
هو الرد الحازم الذي يتطلع اليها الرئيس
زينسكي واوكرانيا على الهجمات الروسيه على
البنى التحتيه
قبل اي شيء ضد المجتمع المدني وضد المنشات
المدنيه والبنيه التحتيه
التي تؤمن
الامدادات الكهربائيه وغيرها لذلك نحن
مستعدين للدفاع عن انفسنا ولكن نحتاج الى
المزيد من الانظمه الدفاع الجوييه المضاده
للصواريخ الروسيه يجب ان تكون في نهايه في
النهايه منزله عن العالم من قبل جميع
المنظمات الدوليه وان يعترف بها كذه اول
ارهابيه لان اصبحت منظمه ارهابيه وهي تريد
ان همم ان تحرم المدنيين من ظروف حياه
طبيعيه حتى تضطر الحكومه للخضوع لشروطهم
السياسيه هذه ليست حرب روسيا لا تحارب
بالجيش ان هات جيم كا منظمه ارهابيه تهاجم
المدنيين وهذا يحدث هنا اؤكد ان بالنسبه
للجيش الاوكراني هذه الضربات الصاروخيه لا
تؤثر على الجيش باي حال من الاحوال كل
القوات العسكريه جاهزه تماما للقيام
بمهماتها العسكريه ومستعده لطرد الروس من
اراضينا
قبل قليل ضيفنا اندريس من موسكو قال ان
الهدف من ضرب البنيه التحتيه هو الدفع
باوكرانيا الى طاوله المفاوضات ومعلوم
بانها ترفض حاليا هذا الخيار هل تعتقد بان
المزيد من الضربات على البنا التحتيه قد
يجعل من هذا السيناريو ممكنا
مراد
اي مجال لهذا كل ما تزيد الضربات بهذا
الشكل وبالصواريخ كلما ااه يزداد اصرار
الشعب والحكومه
ضد روسيا والمفاوضات معها وسوف تتوحد نظره
يجب علينا هذا ما نحن نثق به يجب علينا ان
ننتصر على روسيا بالسلاح وهم غير مستعدين
للمفاوضات انهم ارهابيين ولا يستخدموا
الارهاب ولا احد يتفاوض مع الارهابيين
وبما ان الروس يتصرفون كارهابيين الان
كثير همم لذلك لن نقوم في هذه الظروف
بالتفاوض معهم ولا في حاله من الاحوال حتى
ننتصر عليهم في اراضي المعركه وهذا ما
قاله السيد الرئيس والشعب يدعمه في هذا
شكرا
المستشار في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ورئيس المركز الاوكراني للامن والتعاون
نبقى مع الحرب وتداعيتها فبعد ان تبنى
البرلمان الاوروبي قرارا يصف روسيا بانها
دوله راعيه للارهاب وتستخدم وسائل ارهابيه
قالت رئيسه البرلمان الاوروبي روبيرتاسولا
ان موقع البرلمان على الانترنت تعرض لهجوم
الالكترونيه واضافت ميتسولا في تغريده ان
البرلمان الروبي يتعرض لهجوم الكترونيا
معقد اعلنت جماعه موليه مسؤوليتها عنه
واشارت الى ان خبراء تكنولوجيا المعلومات
في البرلمان الاوروبي
يقاومون الهجوم ويحمون الانظمه
وفي ارتدادات الحرب على السوق الطاقه عجز
سفراء الاتحاد الاوروبيه عن التوافق على
اليه الحد الاقصى ومستوى اسعار النفط
المقترح وكانت دول مجموعه السبع وفقا
لمصادر تحدثت لموقع بلومبرج تسعى الى فرض
حد اقصى لسعد النفط الروسي بين 65
دولارا للبرميل وهو مستوى سيكون اكثر سخاء
لموسكو مما توقعه الكثيرون عندما اقترحت
مجموعه الدول السبع هذه الفكره لاول مره
واضافه المصادر ان هذا النطاق هو اعلى
بكثير من تكلفه الانتاج في روسيا واعلى من
ما كانت بعض البلدان تدفع اليه لكن العديد
من الدبلوماسيين في الاتحاد الاوروبي
قالوا ان المستوى المقترح مرتفع للغايه
ويتماشى مع المتوسط التاريخي لما قبل حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا
الان الى التصعيد في شمال سوريا فمع
استمرار غارات تركيا وقصفها على ما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه يؤكد رئيس التركي
تصميم بلاده على التحرك لتامين حدودها
الجنوبيه الرئيس اردوغان جدد اتهامه ليون
دوليه بعدم الوفاء بوعودها بشان الضمانات
الامنيه في اشاره ضمنيه للولايات المتحده
وروسيا هذه الاثناء يجري رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه اتصال لافتا مع نظيره
التركي
لا تراجع تقولها انقره عن عمليه شحذتها
المخلبه والسيف معه
في شمال الشرقيه
على مواقع ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وتقول تلك القوات التي تشكل
وحداته حمايه الشعب الكرديه فصي لها
الابرز الى القصف طاول مواقع لها في رفي
حلب ولقاء مشلي حتى اللحظه تتصدر ضربات
الجويه المشهد لكن واضح ان الاتراك يعدون
لعمليه
سيطلقونها كما يقولون في الوقت المناسب
العمليات التي بداناها بالطائرات
والمدفعيات والمسيرات هي عباره عن بدايه
فقط اليوم لدينا اصرار اكبر على ضمان امن
كامل حدودنا الجنوبيه من انطاكيا وصولا
الى هاكاري وبينما تستمر عملياتنا الجويه
من دون انقطاع سنقوم بالقضاء على
الارهابيين برا في الوقت المناسب لنا
انه موعد قد يعجل به سلوك قوى يقولوا
الاتراك انها اعطت ضمانات بعدم استهداف
بلادهم من مناطق سيطرتها لكنها لم تفي
بوعودها
بانتظار تلك اللحظه يجدد الامريكيون
تفهمهم الهواجسه التركيه ولكن ايضا رفضهم
اي عمل عسكري في سوريا او العراق اما
الروس فيحاولون كما يبدو اقناع تركيا
بالعدول عن فكره تنفيذ عمليه بريه في
الاراضي السوريه يقول مبعوث رئيس الروسي
الى سوريا الى بلاده تعول على انساط تركيا
لنداءاتها والامتناع عن مزيد من التصعيد
هناك
المسؤول الروسي لا يفوت السانحه لاتهام
الولايات المتحده بتباع ما يعتبرها سياسه
مدمره شماليه سوريا بل انه لا يستبعد ان
اشاره اعطيت لمن وصفهم بالاكراد للقيام
بعمليه الارهابيه في اسطنبول على احد وصفه
تلك العمليه هي ما حرك ضربات الجويه
والمدفعيه التركيه على اهداف تابعه لوحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه في سوريا ولحزب
العمال الكردستاني الذي يتخذ مقرات له في
العراق
مازالت تنظيمان الكرديان ينفيان اي دور
لهما في هجوم اسطنبول الدامي لكن القياده
التركيه تقول في اصرار ان وقت المحاسبه قد
حان
بلاده تواصل عمليتها العسكريه عبر غارات
جويه
بالارهابيين في شمال سوريا والعراق اوضح
ان هذه العمليه تستهدف حزب العمال
الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكردي
وتنظيم الدوله
حتى الان تم استهدافه 471 موقعا والهجمات
التي ينفذها الارهابيون دون تفرقه بين
مدنيين وعسكريين تظهر مدى الوضع الصعب
الذي يتعرض له الارهابيون يجب علينا
القضاء عليهم في اسرع وقت لا مشكله لدينا
ابدا مع الاكراد او مع العرب وهدفنا
الوحيد هو الارهابيون وهم حزب العمال
الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب وتنظيم
الدوله وحان وقت محاسبتها
لوريال ده يشتريال مان
السياسي ومن بنسلفانيا الدكتور اندرويد
المدير السابق لقسم سوريا في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي والمستشار السابق للمبعوث
الامريكيه الخاصه الى سوريا دكتور اندرو
كيف تفهمون انتقادات الرئيس التركي
لمن قال بانها الدول عظمى لم تلتزم
بتفاهماتها مع تركيا فيما يتعلق بالوضع
بشمال سوريا وشمال العراق
بيساعدات قديمه العهد للدعم الامريكي
لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وعلى وجه الخصوص
دعم تلك الوحدات المسلحه في شرق سوريا
والتي بالطبع الاتراك يرون في قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه فرع عن حزب العمال الكردستاني
والهجوم الارهابي الاخير في اسطنبول وطبعا
مثل هذا العمل هو عمل حساس وهذا احد
الاسباب
والسبب الاخر هو الاتصالات بين تركيا
وروسيا والولايات المتحده حول مطالب تركيا
فيما يتعلقوا بدعم امريكا لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه كله هذا جعلت هذا الامر في
صداره طاقات بين البلدين الان هل تركيا
ماضيه في عملياتها رغم الدعوات الامريكيه
الروسيه لعدم الافراط باستخدام القوه او
حتى رفض قيام اي عمليه عسكريه في شمال
العراق وسوريا
الرئيس التركي قد تاكد على ان تركيا سوف
تفعل كل ما تحتاجه اليه لضماني امنها
حدودها
وضماني امن مواطنيها اذا لو كان هناك حاسه
لعمليه
فان العمليه البريه اذا كانت ضروره ستبدا
تركيا بشانها لكن كما نعلم الان ال- ال-
العمليات تتخذ شكل الضربات الجويه وتركيا
تسن هذه الضربات ضد منظمات حزب العمالقه
الارهابيه لكن من جهه اخرى وكما تعلمون
فانه هناك مفاوضات لما
بيننا وزاره الخارجيه التركيه ونظيرتها
الروسيه والامريكيه لانهم هم جزء من هذا
القضيه هم امريكا وروسيا موجوده ثاني داخل
سوريا وتسيطراني على اراضي وفي العام 2019
وعدسات تركيا
باجباري قوات حزب المالكردستاني يبتعد على
الاقل الى مسافه 30 40 كيلو متر عن الحدود
التركيه ومايك في اثناء بالرئيس الامريكي
كان في تركيا واتفق مع تركيا
المتحده
لمعودها من جهتها روسيا ايضا كانت
وعدت بان في منطقه
رفعت لانها لم تسمح
الارهابيه ان تقع
ثاني ضد تركيا وفي سنوات الماضيه
اسمعي يعود الى الدكتور همم دكتور اندرو
همم الاتصال الاخير بين همم هيئتي الاركان
الامريكيه والروسيه هل
باعتقادك يحدد
سقف العمليه العسكريه التركيه ضد وحدات
سوريا الديمقراطيه
يمكن لها ان تفعل ذلك لكن
التفاهمات مثل هذا النوع هي تتعلق بروسيا
وامريكا ولا تتعلق بتركيا رغم ان تركيا
عاده تنصق او تبلغ الاولاد المتحده قبل
ايه تحرك لها داخل سوريا ولكن المتحده
تراقب عن كسب التحركات العسكريه التركيه
علينا ان نراقب الاحداث في الاسابيع الق-
المقبله لكن يبدو لان تركيا جاده في
التدخل داخل على الاقل جسر من سوريا
والثار هو اين بالضبط هذا ما لا نعرفه همم
يقول الدكتور اندرو بان تركيا جاد
بالتدخل ما الذي قد يدفعها لتطوير هذه
العمليات العسكريه لو تصبح بريتا
اه
يونايتد
المتحده
نهايه خطوات جاده لاجبار لحزب العمال
كردستاني ليبتعد على الاقل 36 كيلومترا عن
حدود تركيا
التي ستدبر تركيا على البدء بعمليه بريه
وايضا ان لم تفعل ذلك تركيا
مع الشعبين الكرديه العربي تركيا تتصرف ضد
منظمه بعينها ونحن وصلنا الى هذا النقطه
بعد عمليه ارهابيه وفي وقعت في قلب
اسطنبول
وقتل العشرات وجرح قتل وجرحى العشرات اذا
بتركيا لم تسمح بالتكرار مثل هذه الهجمات
والحل الرئيسي هنا لتفادي ذلك وتنظيف هذه
المناطق الحدوديه من الارهابيين هذه هي
نظره تركيا الى ما يحدث داخل سوريا لهذا
السبب اعتقدوا ان تركيا لن تتراجع وبل
ستتقدم الى الامام لكن كما قال ضيفكم
الاخر لا نعرف متى
سيبداوا ذلك
ما الذي يعيق الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
من الاستجابه لها واجس تركيا في شمال
العراق وسوريا
باكتضاض لو سمحت
الامر كله حقيقه ليس الامر انها ستستجيب
او تستمع لان الولايات المتحده تفهم ان
تركيا ترى في حزب العمال الكردستاني
وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تنظر اليها نظره
مختلفه عن نظره المتحده
وايضا
ربما الخلاف في جوهره يكمل في انه هل
سيكون هناك هجوم بري الحاجات التركيه لكنه
في نفس الوقت همم
يخربوا الوضع الراهن وخاصه في القتال ضد
تنظيم الدوله في شرق سوريا والاتاء على
الضغوط على تلك المنظمه هذا هو نوع الحوار
التي الذي يجب ان يفهمها ويظهر الى العالم
شكرا لكم الدكتور اندروا في سلفانيا
والسيد اوزجان تيكيت في انقره
[موسيقى]
تاتي الى قرار الاداره الامريكيه تعيين
ممثل خاص لشؤون الفلسطينيه حيث نسلط الضوء
على تاريخ العلاقات الفلسطينيه الامريكيه
لا تعترف واشنطن بدوله فلسطين وليس
للولايات المتحده اي مكتب تمثيليا
دبلوماسي او قنصليه داخل اراضي السلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه المعلنه بمقتضى اتفاق
اوسلو عام
1993 ورغم ان العلاقات بين الحكومه
الامريكيه ومنظمه التحرير كممثل للشعب
الفلسطيني قائمه منذ السبعينيات فان
الولايات المتحده لم تسمح بفتح مكتب
المنظمه في واشنطن الا عن
1994 عندما الغي الرئيس بيل كلينتون قانون
ينصه على عدم احقيه الفلسطينيين في فتح
مكاتب لهم على الاراضي الامريكيه في اواخر
عام 2002 قرر رئيس الاسبق جورج بوش خفض
التمثيل مكتب منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه في
الولايات المتحده بحجه عدم احترام منظمه
التحرير والسلطه الفلسطينيه لبعض
تعهداتهما لكن في يوليو تموز من العام
2010 قررت الرئيس باراك اوباما رفع مستوى
تمثيل المنظمه ليصبح المفوضيه العامه
لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه في واشنطن وهو
مستوى بروتوكوليون اعلى من وضعها السابق
وسرعان ما تبخرت تلك الخطوه باستصدار
اداره ترامب قرارا من الكونغرس في نوفمبر
2017 يشترط استمرار مكتب منظمه التحرير
بامتناع الفلسطينيين عن ملاحقه اسرائيل
امام المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه على
جرائمها وبنضمام فلسطين رسميا الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه اغلقت اداره الرئيس
ترامب مكتبه المنظمه في واشنطن عام 2018
فضلا عن نقل السفاره الامريكيه الى القدس
واغلاق القنصليه الامريكيه العامه في
القدس الشرقيه التي تاسست على الف و 844
خلال حملته الانتخابيه تعهد الرئيس
الامريكي جو بيدن مرارا وتكرارا باعاده
فتح القنصليه الامريكيه للفلسطينيين
بالقدس الشرقيه مما شكل
مبررالسلطه الفلسطينيه لاعاده العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده بعد قطعها اسرع اعتراف
اداره ترامب القدس عاصمه اسرائيل ونقل
السفاره الامريكيه اليها وفي سبتمبر من
العام الماضي اكد مشاريعون امريكيون هم
كريس ميرفي و ريتشارد بلوم انساك
وكريسربس ضروره اعاده فتح القنصليه
الامريكيه في القدس الشرقيه لخدمه
الفلسطينيين بشكل افضل وذلك خلال لقائهم
مسؤولين اسرائيل في القدس تحديدا بعد نحو
شهر من ذلك جدد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
تعهد اداره الرئيس ايضا بالمضيق قدما في
خطتها لاعاده فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في
القدس ضمن سماها تعليق العلاقات مع
الفلسطينيين واواخر ايار مايو الماضي وقبل
زياره بيت الشرق الاوسط قال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه نترايس ان واشنطن لا
تزال ملتزمه باعاده فتح قنصليه الامريكيه
في القدس وهي تواصل مناقشه المساله مع
الاسرائيليين مع الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيه
وناقش الموضوع مع ضيفينا ينضم الينا من
واشنطن ديفيد بولجر مدير مكتب الرئيس
والمستشار السابق لشؤون الامن القوميه
الامريكيه وامن نابلس الدكتور رائد ابو
بدويه استاذ القانون الدولي والعلاقات
الدوليه في الجامعه العربيه الامريكيه
مرحبا بكما سيد ديفيد كيف تفهمون هذه
الخطوه من اداره الرئيس فايده
توصي الخير
شكرا جزيلا على اشراكي في هذا النقاش
المهم اداره بعض عندما كان بيض وكان نائما
للرئيس والان هو الرئيس حبذا دائما اسلوب
الدبلوماسيه والتفاوض
والحديث عن الامور بغيت تحلها فهو يشعر
بان هناك حاجه اذا ما تحادث الناس في ما
بينهم فانهم لن يهاجموا بعضهم البعض
القنابل او بالسلاح لهذا السبب هذا ما
اراد العوده
ان الوضع الان مختلفا عن الوقت الذي جاء
فيه الى سده الرئاسه لان رئيس الوزراء
الثانيه في ذلك الوقت كان يغادر منصبها
والان هو عائد اليه
ضد اكثر في اسرائيل ومثل هذا الحوادث
تتكرر لكن امتلاك مبعوث خاصه يكون عنصرا
حيويا وضروريا على الاقل لابقاء على درجه
من الحوار مع السلطه الفلسطينيه
ومع كل الفصائل
ولكي نرى كيف يمكن التوصل او التحرك صوب
السلام
في العلاقات بين الاداره الامريكيه
والسلطه الفلسطينيه
لا لا اعتقد انه هذا المنصب يغير اي شيء
بالعلاقه ما بين السلطه الفلسطينيه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا المنصب
جاء ضمن سياسه الاحتواء الامريكيه
لاستردام
لسلطه الفلسطينيه ومنظمه التحرير بعد
خذلان الفلسطيني من الوعود الانتخابيه
التي
قطعها على نفسه بايدنا اثناء الحاله
الانتخابيه بالانتخابيه وهي اعاده فتح
مكتب منظمه التحرير واعاده فتح القنصليه
الامريكيه في القدس الفلسطينيين وكل هذه
الوعود يعني لم يحققها ايضا لم يستطيع ان
يحققها اثناء حكم بنت لبيد ولن يستطيع ان
يحققها اثناء حكم همم حكومه متشدده قادمه
في اسرائيل باعتقد انه هي كانت همم
تعيين المبعوث هذه هو كان الثمن اللي همم
قدمت قدموا الامريكان استبدالا لفتح
القنصليه في في القدس هذا من جانب من جانب
اخر باعتقد انه همم هذا المبعوث ستكون له
مهمه محدده وحسب ما اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
اللي هو مساعده الجانبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي بذلك التحديات في العلاقه في
ما بينهم وباعتقد ازاله التحديات هي
التحديات قد تكون تحديات اقتصاديه وهذا
ممكن لانه اميركا افرجت عن المساعدات وقد
تكون تحديات امنيه خاصه في ظل التصعيد
الامن في الاراضي الفلسطينيه والتصعيد
المتوقع اكثر في ذي الحكومه يمنيه متطرفه
اما في الجانب التحديات السياسيه فقد اعلن
بايض النفس اثناء زيارته الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بانه صحيح هو يؤمن بحال
الدوريتين ولكن لا يرى ان الظروف في
السياسيه او الظروف الحاليه هي مواتيه
للمضيق قدم في هذا الحال فانا باعتقد انه
همم هذا المبعوث سيكون له دور اكثر في
موضوع الاحتواء التصعيد الامني في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
وبقاء الامور قيد السيطره قدر الامكان
صيدليه بتقدر جانب الفلسطيني غير متفائل
من استحداث هذا المنصب ااه انتم في في
واشنطن بتقديراتكم هل يمهد الى مرحله ما
بين الاداره الامريكيه والسلطه الفلسطينيه
في الحكومه الاسرائيليه من النت الى عهد
اخر والانتر ياهو يعود وهذه مقاربه اكثر
تشددا وان هناك ايضا تغييرات في الجانب
الامريكي مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي سيبقى بعيد
الديمقراطين وهذا ما يبشره بخير لكل من
يعيش في هذه المنطقه لكن للاسف مجلس
النواب سيكون تحت السيطره الجمهوريين
الجمهورينا لهم اكثر تشددا وهم الذين
سيقفون الدفع الاموال فيما يتعلق باكرانيا
وربما حتى مع الشرق الاوسط انا اتفقوا مع
ضيفكم بان هذا من حيث الجوهر
سوف يخلق بيئه يمكن فيها للمحادثات ان تتم
في رايها هذه خطوه اقرب الى امتلاك النوع
من المفاوضات او على الاقل حوار مفتوح بين
الاطراف الثلاثه لهذا السبب اعتقدوا ان
الخطوه ايجابيه واعتقدوا ان الرئيس يمكن
ان يتعامل مع مجلس الشيوخ ويحرك الامور
لانه هناك الكثير من الاصدقاء في الشرق
الاوسط في كلا مجلس الكونغرس لهذا السبب
انا اكثر التفاؤلا مما كنت عليه في الماضي
سيد يقول بانه على الاقل سيجد ارضيه ربما
للتفاوض والحوار كيف تعتقد بان السلطه
الفلسطينيه ستعامل مع هذا المنصب مع السيد
هادي عمر بتحفظ
انا بعتقد السلطه الفلسطينيه ستنتظر يعني
مهمه السيد هادي عمر اذا اذا كان بامكانه
عمل انفراج في في الانسداد الافقي السياسي
مع الاسرائيليين هل وهذا السؤال مهم ويعود
لاداره بعيدا يعني مش منصب عامر تحديدا
ولكن هل لدى اداره
الاراده الحقيقيه لممارسه همم نوع من
الضغوط على الاسرائيليين وعلى حكومه
اسرائيليه متطرفه قادمه من اجل الجلوس على
طاوله المفاوضات مع الفلسطينيين انا مش مش
كثير متفائل في هذا الموضوع لانه يعني حتى
بايد ان لم يستطع عن ان يدفع حكومه لبيد
وحكومه بنت وهي الاقل تطرفا من الحكومه
المتوقع لم يستطيع ان يدفعها للجلوس مع
الفلسطينيين
وخلق اي انفراج السياسيه فانا لا نتوقع
انه في ظل حكومه نتنياهو وظل حكومه اسمه
واترتش بالجفير لا اعتقد انه بايد قادر
على ذلك وخاصه مع مع ما قاله ضيفك سيطرت
الجمهوريين على مجلس النواب صحيح انه مجلس
الشيوخ ما زال يعني تحسيطره الديمقراطيين
ولكن خسروا مجلس النواب وهذا يعني يؤثر
سلبا فيما يتعلق في الضغط على
الاسرائيليين معروف انه الجمهوريين هم من
يساندون اكثر الحكومه الاسرائيليه شكرا
لكم الدكتور رائد ابو بدوي استاذ القانون
الدولي والعلاقات الدوليه في الجامعه
العربيه الامريكيه في نابلس
والسيد ديفيد بونجور مدير مكتب الرئيس
السابق الامن القومي الامريكي في واشنطن
شكرا لكم
اذا تابعنا معكم حصاد الليله منتصف الليل
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهذا استعراضه لاهم
الانباء قبل الانتقال الى الجوله الرياضيه
يوميات المونديال
افاد مراسل الجزيره في القدس ان اسرائيليه
قتل وجرح العشرات في تفجيرين داخل محطتين
للحافلات في القدس الغربيه وقالت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه ان شخصا وضع المتفجرات داخل
حقيبه في المحطتين وان الحقيبتين فجرت عن
بعد واكد السفير الامريكي وان من بين
الجرحى مواطنين امريكيين وقد رفعت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه تاهب في المدينه ومحيطها
بعيده تفجيرين اللذين يعداني اول عمليه من
نوعها في القدس منذ 2000 2016
وفاه وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان رئيس
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي قرر اختصار زيارته
للولايات المتحده والعوده بعد التفجيرين
بجانبه طلب بن كثير المرشح الاقوى لتولي
حقيبه الامن الداخلي في حكومه نتنياهو
الجديده باجتياح الضفه الغربيه
قال نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده ان مجلس الامن سيعقد جلسه مفتوحه
بشان اوكرانيا وضف ان اوكرانيا تعرضت
اليوم لهجمات على البنيه التحتيه ما ادى
الى تفاقم ازمه الطاقه بشكل خطير وكان
الجيش الاوكراني وافاد ان دفاعات الجويه
اسقطت واحدا 51 صاروخا روسيا من اصل 70
استهدفت البنى التحتيه الحيويه في بلاد
وقد ادى القصف ولا انقطاع الطاقه عن ثلاث
محطات للطاقه النوويه وانقطاع الكهرباء
والماء عن كيف ومدن اخرى وقد حذرت منظمه
الصحه العالميه من ان منظومه الصحه في
اوكرانيا تواجه احلى ايام في الحرب بسبب
تضرد قطاع الطاقه
اكد رئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان بلاده
مصممه على التحرك لتامين حدودها الجنوبيه
واضاف ان القوه التي اعطت ضمانات بعدم
استهداف تركيا من مناطق سيطرتها لم تفي
بوعودها وفي كلمه القاها امام كتلته
البرلمانيه شدد اردوغان على ان بلاده
عازمه على البدء في عمليه بريه عسكريه في
شمال سوريا في الوقت المناسب
وقد اجر الرئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
اتصال مع نظيره التركي بينما قال مبعوث
الرئيس الروسي الى سوريا ان موسكو طلبت من
انقره عدم تنفيذ عمليه بريه وسعه في سوريا
كتاب الحصاد شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه
الى اللقاء بامان الله ورعبت
[موسيقى]